hey guys this is andrew from senses.com
so for those who are watching my video
for the first time let me quickly
introduce myself
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong
and i use technical analysis every day
to read the flows
and predict price action so i decided to
make a youtube channel where i'll show
you guys everything that i do at work
and i try to explain everything so that
you can do it yourself
at home so in today's video i want to
make an analysis on
bitcoin let's get into it
[Music]
right guys so i'm doing videos on the
bitcoin since
i started my youtube channel and like i
always say you know i use idiot wave
counting to actually define the market
structure
and then i use trend lines and the
different patterns you know like watch
pattern here
triangle here to actually find the
breakout levels and
enter my trades so here very quickly
guys
i go on the weekly time frame and i show
you my counting since
inception we are actually right now
doing the fifth wave that started at 3
000 and that
is probably going to go to 300 000
in 2022 2023 something like this and the
question we're having is right now what
do we do
should we sell should we buy if you
believe that we go to 300 000
of course you're gonna keep your
bitcoins but the question is where can
you buy
more all right so i'm gonna try to
answer that so i go on a daily timeframe
and i'm gonna lies closer what is
happening and here
i've said that already in my previous
videos but guys you know maybe
all of you didn't watch it so it's
always good to repeat
let's analyze the movement that started
at 5000
in march 20 and let's try to break it
down in five waves
so quite obviously i have one two three
four and five
so we have just finished the third wave
and last time we had a correction it
last for two
three months it was an abc so right now
why i think we have completed this third
wave so
basically idiot wave counting is always
the same thing guys waves up developing
five waves one two three four five and
moves down
developed in three waves abc flat or
zigzag
it can also be a triangle in five waves
abcde
here and the game of idiot wave counting
is to
actually find accounting that is filling
the price action the best and that is
respecting all the rules
all the rules are in the book or in the
training i give you guys for free if you
click on the link of the description of
this video
so here i'm not gonna explain everything
but this is a perfect case guys all
right
we having here my abc so i'm gonna focus
on the purple one that is here
and see if this is complete so i'm gonna
use the orange one that is here let me
make it a bit
bigger and here i have my one two three
four five with the force wave being a
triangle that is very typical this is
the
most common situation and the fifth wave
being an enzyme diagonal
finishing in a wedge pattern one two
three four five
with the force wave entering wave one
territory which is
showing weakness so here and this
beautiful wedge pattern that got broken
retested and then we went
lower i did my last video here i told
you guys that 57 000
would be resistance we didn't even come
back to it we traded
lower so i just did this sum up very
quickly
so that you guys all can follow the next
part of this video
for all the reasons i just gave you we
are bearish we are bearish on the short
term for the next two three months
because we're expecting
a type of correction like we had in wave
two here
of the purple all right this one wave
two was the zigzag so when wave two is a
zigzag usually wave 4 is a flat
so this is what we're expecting so you
already have here
a lot of interesting information you
guys can use a flat correction
is a correction that is doing something
like this
it means two things first we're gonna go
to the support level
very soon which is 42 000 and we're
gonna come back
to the highs as quickly as we went back
to
42 000 before coming back to it again
right
this is the hypothesis i'm i am making
for those who want to buy of course 42
000 is a beautiful level to buy
you can buy slightly above you know some
say 43 000 because
this is the lowest point i have here but
this is forgetting
that we have finished this whole move
all right you need to keep this in mind
that's why idiot wave is very precious
we finished the orange one the one two
three four five is complete
so right now what is happening
is that we're probably gonna correct
something
inside this orange one so you need to
find
high lows not inside the fifth wave
because
it's finished but inside the orange
wave so the highs and the lows are 28
and 42 guys so those are my support
levels
i don't have 43 000 for those who are
wondering
i have a guy maybe he's watching this
video he told me 43
i know why it's because this is the
lowest level here
but this is finished all right this wave
is complete
now we need to take a step back and
focus on
the orange one and the highs and the
lows are gonna give us
the support and resistances that we are
looking for for now we are looking for
support
so that's why i believe that 40 000
would be the level so of course you can
buy 43 42 500 you know slightly above
then we're gonna have a flat correction
of course i can't be sure of that it
might be a zigzag
it might be as well something like this
it can happen that we have two
consecutive zigzags
it's just not the most common situation
so
we have two scenarios either we have a
zigzag or a flat
now let's go back on the shorter term
and
try to answer that question right so
because i'm giving you some guidelines
for the coming month but you guys maybe
want some guidelines for the coming days
so let's do it now we know that we
started a new
corrective pattern and that moves down
now we're gonna develop in five waves
and moves up are gonna be corrective
moves down a motive moves up a
corrective because we're going down
now the counting is reverse so i need to
find
one two three four five in waves that
are going down
right this is idiot wave theory
so here let's do accounting on the
shorter term
so you can find different stuff but
doing something like this would make
sense for me
right here i have a one two three four
five this
impulsive move here is likely to be a
three right
let me put it in a different color
because third wave
are the most impulsive ones so this
counting makes sense to me
it can also be something like this right
it's possible as well but for now i have
here
five waves that i can count that looks
good to me
and i'm expecting a zigzag correction
so on the upside to arrive right now so
i don't know if the zigzag is going to
be like this but it's possible
and then i expect three wave again so
it's a flat correction
so it's a b c inside my flat so
i'm expecting something like this
this is the typical stuff i would see
guys for this move down
so if you're wondering where you can
catch the rebound
because you want to exit your position
to buy lower which is for me a nice
day trader move but carefully as if
you're not day traders
and you're not at ease with everything
i'm saying here maybe just
keeping your bitcoin is a good idea as
well
i mean it all depends and if you think
that the bitcoin run is over
just get out of it and you know you can
come back when you're gonna see higher
highs and higher lows
it's fine too but here let me give you
my
preferred scenario it's something like
this and we need to find
here some resistance on the upside the
resistance is going to be given
by this 200 moving average guys all
right
so i'm probably gonna have something
like this
so i don't know when but i can give you
a bit of information
that it might be around the 28th of
april guys so
around the 28th of april you we might be
trading around 55 000.
if we do keep this in mind it means i
was right
and if i'm right about that i'm probably
right about what is gonna
happen next and then we're gonna have
our
flat correction all right
so this is what i'm expecting guys i'm
giving you here a very detailed view
of course you know the probability i'm
100 right
here is close to zero let's be honest
but the probability i'm having
a lot of good levels and a lot of market
price market price action development
correct
is actually quite high because i was
right
the whole way up and here i think that
what i'm seeing
looks very nice and very in line with
what we expect in idiot wave theory
so if the theory is followed properly on
the short term
and on the long term i expect it to keep
uh follow this rules because probably a
lot of traders are using the theory to
enter and exit the trades
which is making it work better it's like
a self-fulfilling prophecy kind of
and i expect the theory to keep being
valid for the coming
days weeks month years and very quickly
while we go to 300 000 i use fibs to do
that and i just measure
this wave so that's why you get wave
counting is the first thing
to do because if you don't know it's a
three how can you know
where it's gonna go like where to do
your extension
so you measure the second wave to find
the top of the fifth wave
so it might go to 80 000 maybe
80 or 93 thousand all right guys so
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub like and like button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
sure
i'll see you guys